The final topic of the course
is clinical psychology,
also known as a normal
psychology or psychopathology.
And this for many of us is what
psychology is really about.
It's about mental illness.
It's about clinical psychologists.
Um,
and um,
we started talking about this when a
Dr. Nolan Huxson mark gave her guests
lecture last week and I'm going
to continue through this today.
Uh,
it is a topic of tremendous scientific
importance but also a topic of great
personal importance for many of us.
Many of the people in this
room have been mentally ill,
strictly speaking at some
point in their lives.
Um,
some of you are under some sort of therapy
or treatment or medical intervention
right now.
Some of you are on Prozac or Zoloft or
Ambien or Wellbutrin or any of those
other medications to a,
to deal with psychological
problems you're facing.
Others are also talking to psychiatrists,
psychologists,
social workers,
and other people.
Um,
many of you who are not at this point
mentally ill will become mentally ill,
uh,
during your stay at Yale.
Um,
and um,
it,
this is a difficult period
in many people's lives.
And as the period of people's lives
where mental illness emerges in a,
in many of us,
by one estimate,
one half of all college graduates in the
United States and a number is very high
with college graduates,
highly educated people.
One half of you will have some sort
of mental illness in your life,
um,
serious enough to require
some sort of treatment.
Those of you not directly
affected with mental illness,
um,
yourselves,
we'll no doubt experienced
your loved ones,
your family,
your friends,
getting some sort of illness,
um,
be it Alzheimer's or schizophrenia
or depression or some sort of anxiety
disorder.
So the personal importance of,
of clinical psychology
to personal importance of
understanding what can go wrong
and how best to treat it
simply can't be underestimated.
Now,
when we target about mental disorders,
the scope of this is very broad.
It includes the prototypical
schizophrenia would,
you could see on the streets of new haven,
somebody walking and gesturing
and talking to themselves.
It's,
and I'm screaming.
Um,
it includes alcohol addiction and
cocaine addiction and other addictions.
It includes somebody with
down syndrome or autism.
I'm an old person losing his memory,
a teenager falling into a deep depression,
somebody with a severe social phobia to
the extent that he or she can't leave
the house,
then there are also very hard cases
where it's difficult to say one way or
another.
That guy's photographing
me as I'm talking to.
It's freaking me out.
Um,
and kind of a social phobia way.
it was difficult cases where it's just
hard to tell mental illness from just
from just bad behavior,
um,
in general.
Um,
so,
so consider a killer without a conscience
or a mobster like John Gotti is he
mentally ill?
Um,
and this is a question which is a deep
one and we'll wrestle with it a little
bit actually towards
the end of this lecture.
What about somebody who acts in
a kind of unusual or Zany way?
Um,
this is originally supposed
to be a picture of a,
of the character Kramer on Seinfeld,
but given his unusual antics
in the last few months,
it could be a picture of
the actor who plays him.
We've gone to all sorts of trouble.
What about someone who is just kind of
wacky at what point his wackiness move
into the domain of mental illness.
Um,
what about the unusual lifestyles
such as extreme altruism?
Batman devotes most of his
life to helping others.
He sleeps one hour a night and this hour
is fraught with nightmares and then he
fights crime.
What about somebody?
And this was a case report in
the New Yorker a few months ago,
who has lots of money and a loving family
and has his kidney removed to help a
stranger.
And he says,
I have two kidneys.
That's minor pain,
minor operation.
I could save someone's life.
His wife says,
you're mentally ill.
That's just crazy to do that.
Where do we draw the line?
And so there are these great
philosophical and moral questions over the
boundaries and how to
think about mental illness.
So how should we think about
mental illness as well?
There's some answers we
could quickly dispense with.
It used to be thought that severe
mental Ellis was a result of demonic
possession.
Um,
if you read the Gospels,
Jesus Christ wandered around a lot,
met crazy people,
and exercise the demons from their bodies.
It was a common way of
thinking about craziness.
We now believe that this is not true.
What about yes,
it's not true.
What about social social deviants?
Some people including the psychiatrist,
um,
Tom has us claim that when we
label somebody as mentally ill,
this is not a medical decision.
It's rather a social decision,
um,
designed to ostracize people who deviate
from society's norms to ostracize them
and rid them of moral agency.
It's not that we disagree with them.
It's not even that we see them as evil.
Rather we see them as sick.
And as such,
we don't even have to core to them the
respect that we accord to criminals.
Now,
this is not entirely unreasonable view
in many countries around the world.
Um,
desistance people who,
who,
who argue against the state are often
determined to be mentally ill and thrown
in asylums.
Uh,
blacks in the United States who tried
to escape from slavery were described as
having a mental illness.
Why would they want to do so unless
they were mentally ill up until,
um,
1973 to be a homosexual to be gay would
count in the official records of how we
classify illness as being mentally ill.
And many people saw this and we see this
now not so much as reflecting a sort of
unbiased medical analysis,
but rather as reflecting biases
that people have against gay people.
And these are political and
social and moral biases.
They're not objective medical judgments.
Uh,
even now I've been,
I've been recording every president that
has been the president of United States
in,
in my memory,
including Bush and the particularly
Clinton has been described it by,
by his opponents,
not merely as awful evil,
terrible hate his policies,
but as mentally ill every part,
every president at some point or another,
some bright intelligent person figures
to call a psychopath and put that in Time
magazine.
Um,
now put aside whether the extent
to which the things are accurate.
Point being that we
often use medical labels,
particularly labels like psychopath,
schizophrenia,
delusional to,
to ostracize and pick out
people we disagree with.
At the same time though,
this is not entirely right.
People go too far when they say there's
no such thing as mental illness.
Um,
some people are mentally ill in
a very real sense of illness.
In the same sense,
we would describe somebody as physically
ill if they were to have cancer.
Um,
this illness,
um,
damages their functioning.
They cannot function well.
They do not tend to be more creative or
more productive or more vivacious rather
for them.
With very few exceptions,
possibly some exceptions
revolving around mania.
As Dr. Nolan Huxson my discuss with
very few exceptions being mentally ill,
it's just very bad for
you in every possible way.
Um,
moreover,
when people treated,
when people get better,
they become more competent,
happier,
better able to participate in the work,
and they do not choose to go back to
their mental illness suggesting that it
really is illness in a serious sense.
And so the modern treatment
of psychological disorders
treats them as disorders
like medical disorders.
Schizophrenia is as much a disease as
cancer and should be thought of in the
same way.
Um,
there's a whole field of abnormal
psychology of tremendous scope.
We've already discussed many mental
illnesses in the context of um,
other things.
So for instance,
we talked about Amnesia in the
context of memory and how it works.
We talked about autism in the
context of social reasoning.
There are many more and I'm
not going to read through them.
These are the major categories
just for people's interests,
um,
from the diagnostic and standard manual.
Okay.
You don't have to,
you're not responsible for all of these.
Um,
and this is an illustration which
people might find interesting of sex
differences in these,
in the major disorders.
Um,
and the patterns as you
could see are kind of neat.
Um,
women are more prone to have anxiety
disorders and mood disorders.
Um,
men are much more likely to
suffer from substance disorders,
particularly alcoholism.
Um,
schizophrenia,
it sort of evenly matched,
but antisocial personality disorder,
sometimes known as sociopathy or
psychopathy is predominantly male.
And we'll turn to that a bit later.
Here are the major ones
which I want to review today.
Um,
I'm not going to talk about mood disorders
at all because this was the topic of
the suburb lecture we heard last week,
but I want to quickly
review schizophrenia.
The class of disorders
known as anxiety disorders,
the class of disorders known as
dissociative disorders and the class of
disorders known as personality disorders.
And these are the main
psychological problems.
If,
if when a psychologist or a
psychiatrist does his or her work,
they're predominantly focused on
somebody who has one of these problems.
Um,
some of them are rare,
but some of them such as anxiety
disorders and mood disorders are,
our strikes are very common.
Okay.
Um,
about 1% of the world's population
suffers from schizophrenia.
And
this is the most common reason
for being in a mental hospital.
And the reason for that is because of
its severity because of how terrible an
illness it is.
Um,
schizophrenia next had been
described as the of the 20th century,
but people pointed out in
the last hundred years,
people who are schizophrenia or just
there was no place for them in society.
They're shunned or rejected.
We have no idea how to treat
them or how to help them.
The roots of schizophrenia,
um,
come from the term split,
uh,
and mine.
But the idea is there
was a split from reality.
It's important to stress the sort of Edom,
a logical point because sometimes people
confuse schizophrenia with something
we'll split personality and they somehow
think schizophrenia refers to having
multiple personalities.
This is incorrect.
Multiple personality disorder is
an entirely different disorder.
Is this sort of dissociative disorder.
Um,
split personality that people with
schizophrenia do not have multiple
personalities.
What they have is a problem
with re relating to reality.
Um,
it's roughly equally split between
the genders but it strikes men um,
earlier and uh,
it happens between,
around these ages and as you can
see roughly and as you can see,
it is this sort of thing that could make
us first occurrence while you were in
college or university.
Yeah.
There are five symptoms,
main symptoms of schizophrenia.
Four of them are the positive symptoms,
meaning things that you do
that you have that's unusual.
One's a negative symptom.
Um,
something that you don't have.
Something has schizophrenia,
lax.
So just to walk through them.
A hallucination is an experience,
a sensory experience that isn't real.
So the most typical hallucinations
are auditory schizophrenia.
Hearing voices they hear sounds,
particularly people telling them
to do things that aren't real.
Sometimes there auditory
or visual hallucinations or
hallucinations of smell and
taste.
But a typical hallucination is,
um,
is auditory.
Um,
sometimes the voices are seen
from coming from oneself.
And so you could sometimes
stop the hallucinations by
doing things like humming
or counting or holding your mouth.
Ah,
and some schizophrenia,
we'll do this in an attempt to block,
um,
auditory hallucinations.
There are delusions.
The difference between a hallucination
and delusion is a hallucination is a
sensory experience at that's wrong.
That just didn't really happen.
A delusion is a belief that isn't right.
It's a,
it's,
it's a belief that,
that,
that you shouldn't be having.
Now again,
the question of what counts as of
illusion and what counts is as accuracy.
It can be a controversial one.
I,
Richard Dawkins title,
his recent book,
the God delusion,
describing this mass delusion
that many people have,
that they believe there's a supernatural
being who created the universe and was
watching them.
Some people find that offensive to call
it the delusion and people will have
different views.
The delusion,
schizophrenia next have,
um,
tend to be pretty clearly weird and wrong.
Um,
they often tend to believe
they're famous people.
Um,
many schizophrenia have a religious
bent and believe that they're in Jesus
Christ.
In 1959,
there was a Michigan Hospital.
I had three Jesus Christ in it.
Um,
and they would meet and talk.
one theme of delusions is what's
called ideas of reference and ideas of
reference.
Are you think that there's all sorts
of things happening that revolve around
you.
You hear people whispering and you
think they're talking about you.
You pick up the newspaper and you believe
that there was coded messages in it
that are directed towards you.
Um,
you might believe that,
that there's some sort of omnipotent,
powerful force conspiring against you
are trying to manipulate you like aliens
or the FBI,
the CIA,
the government.
You might believe that they have some
sort of evil plan in mind for you.
Um,
there is disorganized speech,
some schizophrenia,
Babel,
they talk and it's nonsense.
Um,
if you listen to a
schizophrenia on the street,
sometimes what they're
saying makes no sense at all.
Not Merely that they're conveying
ideas that are unreasonable,
but it's just garbled.
It's just a mess.
And sometimes they're
disorganized behavior to,
um,
odd motor movements.
The most extreme case of this,
our motor movements described as
catatonic where the person doesn't move,
often freezes in a position.
Those are all positive symptoms.
I'm major negative symptoms
with schizophrenia is
absence of normal thought or
an effect,
an effect meaning emotion.
So some schizophrenia might just not talk.
They might have very
low emotional responses.
They might not care about anything.
The basic psychological misfunction oh,
sorry.
Um,
okay.
There are different
subtypes of schizophrenia.
There are five major subtypes,
but I'm going to focus
on the three major ones.
Um,
the three most interesting ones.
The first one is paranoid schizophrenia.
So paranoid schizophrenia,
ex,
um,
believe that others are spying and
plotting against them and they often have
delusions of grandeur.
They often believe that other
people are jealous of them.
They might believe they
have supernatural powers.
They might believe that their God or,
or a Messiah,
the catatonic schizophrenia
are unresponsive to their
surroundings and often no,
just repeat what people say to them.
They won't generate their own speed.
And finally did this organize
schizophrenia acts are
maybe what you most think
of when you think of
somebody who is insane.
Um,
they make no sense.
They have delusions and hallucinations.
They babble.
They that their actions make,
they could be dangerous,
they could be perceived as dangerous.
There are unable to help themselves or
unable to do anything in their lives.
It's hard to pin down exactly what's
at root of all of these problems.
But a very general summary is that there
is a problem and an inability to put
together your thoughts and perceptions
to sequence them and coordinate them to,
to,
to impose a logical
structure and a reasonable,
realistic temporal sequence
on your experience.
This is the core thing going wrong.
But what happens as a result of this
is you lose contact with others.
You lose social contact.
Losing social contact means you
don't get much reality checking.
If I start acting weird and nobody cares,
I could just get weirder and weirder.
While if I'm in a good social
group of people who care about me,
often the situation could
be brought under control.
So schizophrenia is sort
of a vicious circle.
We had this cognitive problem.
Then you have problems
losing contact with others,
exaggerating the cognitive problem.
And so on
Skit,
a lot of people study the
genetics of schizophrenia.
Um,
it's clear enough that there's
a powerful genetic components.
Um,
I could,
you can tell how much at risk somebody
is for becoming schizophrenia.
Um,
based on the schizophrenia and illness
of their family members in particular,
if you have an identical twin who,
schizophrenia,
your odds are about a half of becoming
schizophrenia herself at the same time.
And we dealt with this as well when
we talked about issues of sexual
orientation.
Um,
the fact that that,
that,
that identical twins,
the odds are only 50% means there has
to be an environmental component to it.
If it was entirely genetic,
it would be 100%.
And so one claim,
one way of looking at it is your jeans
make you vulnerable to schizophrenia,
but whether or not you
become schizophrenia depends
on what happens in your
environment.
You're sensitive to certain triggers.
Some triggers might have an early,
there are some evidence that schizophrenia
is associated with trauma even at the
point of birth.
And there's some other evidence that
schizophrenia is linked to viral
infections.
Um,
as a,
as an example,
there are more,
schizophrenia is born in the winter.
Subtle,
a subtle difference,
but,
but there seems to be a reliable effect
of more schizophrenia born in the
winter.
More people get sick in the winter,
um,
at times when there has been some sort
of epidemic or some sort of plague,
this seems to cause a
jump in the frequency of
schizophrenia was born at that
time.
There's some reason research at ties
schizophrenia to the possibility of
toxoplasmosis,
um,
which is a disorder.
Uh,
carried by cat feces.
The experiment basically involved asking
the parents of schizophrenia x one
question,
did you own a cat when
your child was born?
And if the answer was yes,
it seemed to correspond to a bit
higher odds for schizophrenia families.
Then for non schizophrenia families,
a different sort of um,
trigger is stressful family environments.
Schizophrenia seem to really have
more stressful family environments.
They're non schizophrenia six now
we have to be careful about this.
We have to bring,
we have to return to the sort
of methodological cautions
we had in mind when we
talked about individual
difference research in general.
And remember we talk about the worst
study in the world and one of the features
of this was it was failing to
pull apart cause and effect.
It might be that having a difficult family
environment ups your odds of becoming
schizophrenic.
On the other hand,
it might also be that schizophrenia
children are children who will become
schizophrenia are difficult to deal
with in certain ways causing a family
environment.
So it's not clear whether the effect is
from difficult family environment just
to later schizophrenia
or from schizophrenia to
difficult family environment.
There used to be a very popular
theory of schizophrenia,
which is that it was caused
by excess excess dopamine.
Dopamine you'll remember
is a neurotransmitter.
Um,
and there's some reason take
this seriously drugs that
reduced dopamine provide
some help in reducing symptoms.
And if I give you a drug
that bolstered that,
that that shoots up your dopamine,
um,
that will turn you into,
into a temporary schizophrenia.
Uh,
you get what's called amphetamine
psychosis and you give you,
you can give you schizophrenia symptoms,
hallucinations,
delusions,
that sort of thing.
This,
there might be something to this theory,
but we know now it can't be
complete for at least two reasons.
First,
it doesn't explain the negative symptoms.
It does,
it explains the hallucinations
and delusions and so on.
But it doesn't explain,
um,
the loss of effect,
the quietness,
this stillness.
Also,
there seemed to be some sort of structural
brain differences involving in large
cerebral ventricles,
um,
involving reduced frontal lobe activity.
Suggestion that the problem
with schizophrenia is a
lot more complicated than
others might have it then the
dopamine theory would have it.
Okay.
I'll end with a mystery.
And this mystery is discussed
nicely in the grade textbook.
Um,
the,
the symptoms of schizophrenia,
the prevalence of schizophrenia
is similar wherever you go,
but less industrialized countries
have a better rate of recovery from
schizophrenia than industrialized
countries and nobody really knows why.
I listed here three possibilities.
Um,
one is that the families that were,
that in a less industrialized country,
there's more latitude.
And so there's less
critical bless criticism,
there's less use of
antipsychotic medications,
antipsychotic medications
help with the symptoms,
but they might also impair recovery.
And finally,
if you think of schizophrenia
as a transient disorder,
maybe that will in some sense in some way,
make that more likely to actually happen.
The second sort of disorder I want to
talk about much more common than the 1% is
schizophrenia is a class of
disorders known as anxiety disorders.
MMM.
The primary disturbance and
anxiety disorders is anxiety.
You have a lot of anxiety.
It's persistent.
Um,
either anxiety or,
um,
or maladaptive behaviors
to reduce anxiety.
Now,
everybody experiences anxiety.
If you didn't experience anxiety,
you'd be a very strange person.
He probably wouldn't function
very well in the world,
but you have an anxiety disorder
when you experienced too much of it.
We experienced too much of it.
It's uncontrollable,
it's unreasonable and
it messes up your life.
And there's quite a few anxiety disorders.
The main,
the simplest one is this
generalized anxiety disorders where,
um,
and this is about one in 20 people
will get at some point in their lives,
um,
and you worry all the time.
You're just very anxious.
You're just worried all the time.
And it could be paralyzing.
It could give you physical
symptoms like headaches,
stomach aches,
muscle tension and irritability.
MMM.
There's some evidence that generalized
anxiety disorder has a genetic component
that is somehow related
to major depression.
And it does seem to have,
it's possible routes in some
sort of childhood trauma.
And so the model,
some people give for this
is when you are young,
something really bad happens to you.
Um,
this makes you hypervigilant.
You don't trust the world,
bad things could always
happen around the corner.
And because you're hypervigilant,
um,
you are more prone to develop
generalized anxiety disorder after,
um,
after a difficult life event.
A second sort of anxiety disorder,
which we already discussed in class
are phobias and phobias or intense
irrational fears.
They could focus on objects,
events,
and social settings.
Here's a nice diagram of different phobia,
different things and the proportion
of people who are afraid of it.
And the point of this diagram
isn't with the details.
It's really,
um,
it's,
it's rather to give you a feeling for
the fact that some things most everybody
is afraid of are a lot
of people are afraid of.
And some things,
not many at all.
Um,
the big phobic object we know
from previous lectures is snakes.
About 40% of the population
say they're afraid of snakes.
How many people here are afraid of snakes?
Okay.
And then there's a
really terrifying thing.
Mice,
how you were afraid of mice.
Mice are the worst things in the world.
Um,
and then cats.
And if you're afraid of cats,
that's really unusual.
Not many people are afraid of cats.
Um,
there's a classical conditioning model
of phobias which we are all familiar
with,
but we are all familiar with why
it is not a very good theory.
A lot of people who are afraid of snakes
have never had had a bad experience
with snakes.
Moreover,
a lot of people who have
had bad experiences with
things like car crashes and
being electrocuted on the socket or,
or,
or a shooting,
seeing a gun during a shooting
do not develop phobias.
This lead gives rise to a much more
plausible theory known as the preparedness
theory,
which says that we have evolved to be
sensitive to certain phobic objects,
objects that were dangerous to us in our
evolutionary history and were prone to
develop phobic responses to this.
The final anxiety disorder is
obsessive compulsive disorder.
Um,
obsessions are irrational,
disturbing thoughts that
intrude into your consciousness.
Um,
this is a con hits about two to 3%
of the population and it leads to
compulsion's repetitive actions
performed to alleviate the obsessions.
Um,
for instance,
you might be obsessed with
the idea of your being dirty.
Your hands are dirty or filthy,
that might lead to compulsive washing.
You might believe that God is angry at
you and that might lead to compulsive
prayer.
Uh,
cleanliness and religion
are common themes of um,
obsessive compulsive disorder.
You know,
you often know rationally that these are
unreasonable behaviors where you can't
help yourself from doing them.
Um,
sometimes I check it,
sometimes they get the word I left my
door unlocked and I run back and checked
it,
check it.
But I feel it's a little bit of OCD
coming on because I know I locked it,
but did I really lock it?
And then you get work.
Now I'm worried if I locked my door.
Um,
checking and washing.
Checking is what I'm talking about here.
Most common compulsions and it seems to
have a neuro psychological phenomena,
at least a it related to heightened
neural activity in the caudate nucleus.
What's interesting is you might think
obsessive compulsive disorder is a very
sort of Freud,
the end psychoanalytic sort of disorder.
But actually it's treated
quite well with drugs.
Drugs that affect the serotonin level.
Serotonin being a neurotransmitter
can often do good work for obsessive
compulsive disorders.
So if you develop a
disorder and OCD problem,
you might find yourself being
cured simply with medications.
Any,
um,
we've talked about schizophrenia
and anxiety disorders.
Any questions or thoughts so far?
Yes.
Um,
what's the difference
between OCD and Tourette's?
It's a good question.
The question was in relation
to being OCD and Tourette's,
Tourette's is,
is,
I don't know much about it as a
very specific neurophysiological,
uh,
syndrome that doesn't have it.
You don't have obsessive thoughts.
What it leads to is involuntary tick
ticks and tremors and sometimes sort have
shouted obscenities or two words.
And it needs to be very specific to that.
While OCD is much broader and involves
both behaviors but also to behaviors that
are in the service of thoughts.
So that's one way of
thinking about a difference.
Yes.
Can individuals have multiple
disorders like bipolar and skip?
Yes.
The question is,
can individuals have multiple disorders?
Absolutely.
And in fact,
some disorders are Comorbid and that's
just a fancy way of saying they often go
together.
So if you have a severe depression,
for instance,
which is a mood disorder,
you may also have an anxiety disorder.
So yeah,
having one,
unfortunately it doesn't immunize
you against having another yes
coming.
The question was about superstitions.
Um,
I think it's an interesting question.
Would it have never thought of before?
I think it depends on the
severity of superstitions.
So if he doesn't have
a superstition saying,
um,
you know,
step on a crack,
break your mother's back,
which has never been
scientifically proven,
but let's suppose you and,
and then so you just go,
oh,
I kind of,
I just kind of,
or it's bad luck to break
a mirror and that's it.
You just have it and it
doesn't make a big deal to you.
That's harmless.
On the other hand,
if you're a superstition is such that,
um,
that you develop weird
rituals you might have to do,
um,
to carefully walk so you don't step on
any other on any cracks or you might have
to do or if you do,
you might have to go back and start
your whole walk to work over again.
When it gets to that level,
it could creep into OCD and often
obsessive compulsive disorders.
Um,
have a religious or a
magical manifestation where
you believe there's certain
things you must do or
terrible things will happen.
And then that way you can view them as
extreme and build from superstitions.
But simple superstitions
don't tend to be of that,
of that type.
Yes,
I'm back.
The question is,
are people with schizophrenia dangerous?
Um,
as a rule,
statistically it tends not to be the case.
They tend to be much more likely
victims there then harmful.
They tend to be fairly helpless.
You can have a case where it's
schizophrenia might harm somebody,
a paranoid schizophrenia for instance.
I might develop a delusion
and harm somebody.
Um,
and so there are definitely such cases,
but for the most part
again or more victims,
victims that,
that then,
then,
oh,
pressers,
they're more,
they're,
they're very vulnerable because they
aren't capable of dealing with other
people.
They often aren't capable
of defending themselves.
Uh,
one more.
Yes.
The question is how permanent is the
fact that the medication you mean for
schizophrenia?
Yes,
in general,
I think,
I can't think of any exceptions.
Um,
the,
the effects of medication are temporary.
Now that doesn't mean if you
have a belt of OCD or depression,
you have to be a medication
rest of your life.
What could happen is,
um,
for instance,
somebody get a mild depression,
go on something like Prozac or Wellbutrin,
use that time to going to get
their lives back together,
cheer up a bit.
And then when they go off the medication,
they're fine.
But as Professor Nolan
huck cinema pointed out,
unless they develop coping skills,
they're likely to relapse
and get the problem again.
So the,
the physical effects of
medication are always temporary.
We didn't leave anything
that like schizophrenia,
but it can often help
people get out of a problem,
anxiety or depression.
Okay.
Dissociative disorders.
Um,
I'll show you a movie clip and then
we'll go back and talk a little bit about
it.
Let me ask a question
that might seem somewhat
uncaring.
How many of you think he's faking?
How many of you,
how many of you are confident?
There are many people living inside
his head as in a way it's depicted.
Okay.
How many of you were unsure?
How many of you are of two minds?
There's one part of you struggling.
Let's,
let's,
let's go.
We'll go back to him.
Go back then.
Dissociative disorder are disorders
involving this association.
And what people mean by that is literally
at this Association of memory that is,
um,
you become somehow unaware,
separated from pump part
of your identity or history
and you're unable to recall those parts
of your identity in history except
sometimes under special circumstances.
Now,
some degree of dissociation is normal.
There is,
um,
I will,
I have here,
um,
Ben,
actually Dr. Nolan Hok has excellent
abnormal psychology textbook,
a checklist of dissociative experiences,
many of which normal people have
not sure whether one has done
something or only thought about it.
Anybody ever had that common.
Um,
so involved in a fantasy
that it seems real
feeling as though one's
body is not one zone.
Um,
I will also add that experience that
experiments with pharmaceuticals can often
lead to dissociative experiences.
Um,
driving a car and realizing that one
doesn't remember part of the trip.
Talking out loud to oneself when alone
not recognizing one's
reflection in the mirror.
Okay.
That's not very common,
but it is,
it's within a normal range
is within normal range.
Um,
but then you get more severe cases.
and there's three different types.
Dissociative Amnesia,
dissociative fugue,
and associative identity disorder.
Dissociative Amnesia
is illustrating a story
of a woman who sees something terrible.
And as a result,
her memory of that experience
was no longer accessible.
MMM.
It's often known as psychogenic amnesia.
Uh,
the only thing wrong and
here's your memory loss.
And sometimes it's a
selective memory loss.
Um,
but sometimes it could be global.
It says in these movie cases where
you lose your memory because something
terrible has happened and
he would get it back later.
But you have a temporary loss of identity.
The idea is that something
so terrible has happened.
You separate yourself from your
previous identity and your memory.
Um,
over half of people charged with
homicide claimed to have some degree of
dissociative amnesia.
The problem here is that many,
many,
many of those cases
involve alcohol and drugs,
which can lead to some
sort of alcoholic blackout.
Um,
also people could be lying if you're
charged with murder is often a reasonable
thing to say.
I don't remember any of this.
It just kind of as a way to
distance yourself from it.
Dissociative fugue is kind
of weird and interesting.
Um,
the guy's wife leaves him for another man.
Six months later he was discovered
tending bar in Miami beach and calling
himself Martin and he totally wiped
out his past memory and developed a new
identity.
Um,
this is also known as psychogenic.
Phew.
So it's global amnesia,
but there's also identity replacement.
Um,
you leave home,
you develop a new identity
and it's called a fugue state.
This is,
um,
this is my favorite mental disorder.
If I had to get a serious mental disorder,
I would get this because
I'd get to travel.
Um,
when it wears off,
your old identity comes back
and your new identities,
forgotten
vendors,
dissociative identity disorder.
Um,
and this is a story of this woman who,
um,
goes back and forth from
her regular personality to
a personality a of Donna who
was only six years old.
This was originally known as multiple
personality disorder and ideas.
You have two or more
distinct people in one head.
It is,
it is a rare and controversial disorder,
but include some very
famous cases and has been,
um,
uh,
illustrated in many movies and books.
Um,
Cleveland,
a wonderful movie,
primal,
fair fear where Ed
Norton's first big movie,
highly recommended and it's been
tried as a criminal defense.
Um,
the hillside strangler
claimed to be two people,
but he was still convicted,
both of them.
Um,
it typically starts early.
The pattern of dissociation.
Mostly it's women and mostly it involves
some sort of recollection of torture or
sexual abuse.
Also.
And to get back to your question,
can you have more than one,
um,
mental disorder?
At the same time,
people with dissociative disorder often
show symptoms of post traumatic stress
disorder or PTSD.
What causes it?
Well,
it is often to be to cause
caused by severe abuse,
often sexual or physical abuse.
The problem is most people who get abused
don't develop dissociative identity
disorder.
And one idea is that,
is that if abuse plus some sort of
genetic or biological predisposition to
dissociate,
um,
and in fact people with dissociative
identity disorder seems to be very
susceptible.
They're easier to
hypnotize and other people.
And so it might begin as sort of a self,
if not an act of self hypnosis.
You put yourself in a hypnotic trance
to cope with some terrible situation and
you begin to develop new and
separate and distinct personalities.
Now
of the many things I want to talk to you,
I've talked,
spoken about some of
been very controversial.
One issue of controversy which we talked
about was the existence in nature of
so-called repressed memories.
This is another very controversial case
related to the repressed memory case.
Um,
in a reason,
Paul,
less than one quarter of psychiatrists
believe there is such a thing as
associative identity disorder.
Okay.
Why would you doubt that?
Well,
there's,
I'm curious statistics
between 1930 and 1960 there were two
cases in the United States in the 1980s or
20,000 cases.
You cannot go elsewhere from the United
States and find people dissociative
identity disorder.
It seems to be an American phenomenon
and it varies by therapists.
Some therapists and need some hospitals.
Some medical units go decades without
ever seeing anybody at our approaches.
Dissociative identity disorder,
other therapists,
virtually every patient they
have has multiple personalities.
One worry based on these faxes,
dissociative identity disorder isn't
a sense real that Richard really does
believe he's moving from
personality to personality,
but he didn't come into
therapy with that problem.
Rather as therapists gave it to them.
Um,
the claim is that is the result
of suggestion by the therapist,
the therapist,
and they're typically good
people who wish to help.
But the therapist might be in the grips
of a theory involving repression and
multiple personalities and different
selves and encourage either tacitly or,
or overtly their patients to develop
these separate personalities.
Related to,
this is not clear to what
extent dissociative identity
disorder is an extreme
version of normal psychopathology,
sorry,
abnormal psychology.
So people from the philosopher Dan
Dennett to the psychologist Judith Harris
have pointed out that were
different selves in different,
we can consciously play
at the different cells,
but we could also,
um,
just shift personalities depending on
whether we're with our friends or our
family or with strangers.
The claim is that dissociative
identity disorder,
however dramatic it looks,
might merely be an extended version of
this where people as well are to some
extent play acting to make their
therapist and doctors happy.
Any questions about um,
dissociative identity disorder?
Yes.
Dissociative amnesia.
The question that involves a relationship
need associated Amnesia and the retro
grade and Anterior Grade Amnesia
discussed before those other amnesia.
Is that a result of brain damage?
Um,
they tend to be,
if not permanent,
long lasting and severe dissociative
Amnesia is apparently caused by specific
life events and can often
be very short lived there.
Of course all brain events,
but in a crude sense of dissociative
amnesia was more of a psychological
happening then the other sorts of
Amnesia that we talked about in bombing
course,
the cops syndrome and the
patient of h m and so on.
Other questions?
Yes,
and back.
Yes.
What happened in 1960,
there was a very famous case,
I think the case was a case of civil.
Does anybody know?
Teaching fellers are nodding,
but there was a very famous case which
I think was up Sibyl which was made into
a movie and discussed and
had a huge influence on,
on people.
And then they started to
believe that that it was real.
There's a,
there's a type,
the fourth and final type of disorder,
um,
is something which is not actually
discussed in the great textbook,
but it has to do with personality.
And this is interesting
because it probably extends
to some extent too many of
this people,
the people in this room
personality as you remember,
is your way of dealing with
the world in particular.
In particular the way you have
of dealing with other people.
The notion of personality disorders,
um,
is that some personalities are so bad
that they veer off into mental illness.
So,
um,
one personality disorder is a
narcissistic personality disorder.
Everyone likes to talk about
themselves and thinks they're terrific.
This some extent,
some people to a little bit too much,
but if it's really extreme,
they talk,
they,
you could get labeled with a
narcissistic personality disorder.
Um,
you might have an avoidant
personality disorder dependent,
um,
histrionic.
Borderline borderline is really bad.
When people describe you as a
borderline personality disorder,
that just means you're just awful
to be what you're kind of awful.
Um,
here's the paranoid personality disorder.
which is not that you're paranoid
schizophrenia very clearly.
No signs of schizophrenia,
no.
Uh,
hallucinations,
nothing like that.
You just paranoid.
You're just to a greater
extent than normal.
You think other people are against
you and plotting against you.
The most interesting
personality disorders,
um,
in my mind have to do
with violence and crime
and they have to do in particular with
something called antisocial personality
disorder.
Now,
most murderers are not mentally
ill in a medical sense.
They're not mentally ill according
to how clinicians categorize things.
Um,
to some extent,
most people who kill are just normal
people being driven by normal desires,
rage,
jealousy,
hate,
just taken to an extreme,
even mass murderers do
not as a rule appear to be
substantively different from a
psychological point of view.
Um,
in every society.
And,
and honestly,
I wrote,
I wrote the lecture,
the lecture on this quite a while ago,
but given a reason to events,
um,
it,
they sound is a perfectly good
example of what I'm going to say.
Um,
in every society there's a notion of
somebody who has been deeply humiliated,
usually male,
and he's been humiliated
over and over again.
He sees himself as losing status.
And losing status and losing status.
And he tries to get it all back to gain
face with one act of terrible violence
where he takes his revenge over
everybody and then as known as,
as an and as a result,
even though he might die,
he probably will die.
Makes his way to,
to,
to a level of social status.
You would've never,
never gotten before.
Um,
the,
the American term for this
used to be going postal.
Um,
and um,
but,
but this is an old idea.
Stone-Age tribes in Papa New
Guinea had a term for this,
they call it running a muck.
And this is in every
society has this sort of,
there's Matt,
there's normal murders,
there's mass murderers.
And then there's the interesting
cases like serial killers,
like a daughter or son of Sam,
Ted Bundy,
John Wayne Gacy,
even imaginary Hannibal Lecter.
Many of these sort of serial killers
do have some sort of mental illness,
but the mental illnesses are all over the,
um,
there was a guy,
I'm Jerome Rudolph,
who had such a severe fetish for women's
feet that he killed young women and
separate their feet.
And then kept their feet around his house.
Um,
son of Sam was pretty clearly
a paranoid schizophrenic.
He,
he did his murders because
a barking dog told him too.
Um,
I,
Jeffrey Dahmer is a cannibal killer.
He killed people so we could eat them.
And then,
and I asked one of my colleagues and
clinical colleagues what exactly was wrong
with him.
And the person immediately responded.
He has a severe eating disorder.
It was a joke.
It was in very,
very bad tastes.
Um,
a lot of,
um,
a lot of murders,
claimed had dissociative disorders.
It wasn't me who killed the guy.
It was my alter ego,
Fred.
It's not clear how often they're telling
the truth if ever or whether this is a
way of escaping responsibility.
There's a mental illness.
Um,
there's an extreme specific version of
a personality disorder that revolves
around violence.
And this is known as
antisocial personality disorder
is it used to be called moral insanity
now is often called psychopathy.
Some people make a distinction
between psychopaths and sociopaths.
Um,
for the purposes here,
others don't.
And for the purposes here,
I'm going to blend them
into one category is,
and I'll use the term psychopath.
They're typically male.
Um,
they are defined a selfish,
callous,
impulsive.
You're sexually promiscuous.
They seem to lack love,
loyalty,
normal feelings of
affiliation and compassion
and again to all sorts of trouble because
they're easily bored and they seek out
stimulation.
Now when you hear this,
you got to realize that this sort of
person is not necessarily an unattractive
person to imagine or to think about
or even under some circumstances to
encounter.
You have to avoid the temptation
when you think about psychopath,
to think about a guy like this,
to think of a Hannibal Lecter.
Um,
the most famous psychopath
of course is James Bond,
who's a perfect psychopath in every
regard as played by him and also by Sean
Connery and Roger Moore and
Timothy Dalton characters were not.
Psychopaths could give
a whole course on that.
Um,
is this an illness?
Well,
again,
this is one of the hard cases.
Psychopaths don't come in for treatment.
James Bond would never go
to a therapist and say,
have a problem with promiscuity
in my life of adventure.
Why is it that I don't have this need to
settle down and have kids and be a one
woman man?
They don't have a problem with it.
Um,
other people often have a problem with it,
but,
but it's not clear that's enough
to make it a mental disorder.
Also,
a lot of psychopaths are
reasonably successful.
Now this gets complicated because
psychologists study psycho pass,
but the psychopaths that they study are
by definition unsuccessful psychopaths.
And what some people have
argued is the real psychopaths,
the successful ones are the
ones that run the world,
that excel in every field because they
are successful enough that they don't
look like psychopaths.
They have no conscience,
no compassion,
love,
loyalty.
They're cold blooded and ambitious,
but they don't go around making it so
obvious that we throw them in prison.
And so it's an interesting and
subtle and complicated case.
Um,
the final section and I'll
start this and then we'll,
we'll,
we'll go five minutes
into this and then move,
continue at,
uh,
next week with the final
class concerns therapy.
Now,
the most interesting thing for us to
deal with is the question of does therapy
work.
And there's a lot to be said about this.
Um,
the history of therapy has
been gruesome and unsuccessful.
Um,
again,
to be mad was to be viewed as
to be in league with the devil.
And so people who have mental
illnesses were tortured to death,
Burns,
sent out to sea,
and so on.
In the 18th century,
they were thought of as degenerates
and sent away from society.
In the 19th century there was
a brief blast of compassion,
um,
where pinel tried to
have mental hospitals.
And then,
um,
and then there were all sorts of,
since then,
all sorts of medical treatments
that were considerably less
successful.
And this brief video,
we'll summarize some of the
previous medical treatments.
I often wonder a hundred years from now,
how am I going to look
at our current therapies,
um,
and whether it will see them as equally
barbaric and stupid as we look at the
therapies in the past.
Um,
what I'll begin next lecture with is a
very quick discussion of what therapies
work,
uh,
of the ones currently available.
And then we'll end the class and
this will be somewhat short class.
I end the class with a
discussion of happiness.
Um,
there was an optional thing I'll add,
which is,
um,
which is you're reading responses are
done and you'll have the opportunity to
make comments on the class
in anonymous evaluations.
But what I'm kind of interested in
is if people could send me an email,
and this is entirely optional,
but the most interesting thing
that we've covered in this class,
I'm curious what people think it is.
And it's something which I could try
to build upon for future classes.
So again,
this is optional.
Just give it a subject heading,
intro,
psych and send it to me
if you choose to do it.
And I'll see you on Wednesday.